Now... lets just get it over with
Lets just.. talk about it, let's address the elephant in the room
my background has changed
I KNOOOOW *laughs like a bull*
nothing else is goin on here okay??
i am still the same
i am still the loveable ol' 2014 pewdiepie
NOTHING HAS CHANGED DAMMIT!!
I'm the same GOD DAMN BOI
today we're playing the greatest game of all the time
Cam Studio.
the media's given me a lot of labels, a lot of names ( Swedish meatball)
what people don't really know it's that
I'm extremely  misogynistics.. misege mi-mis
m-misogynist our high score is 16,000 (fabulous!)
today, we're going to beat that high score
as my name is pewdiepie. HO! HO! HOE!
THAT ASS! What's the word for a
g-bi-big vagina because the in Sweden we call
it bullfitta, what do you call it in English
'cause that was, uh, that was
definitely a bullfitta. bull pussy.
ok, well alright well I guess *laugh* .. guess it's that  simple
ok
thick-ass we're going with thick asses
today boys and girls, because I am not a
misogynist-netics so basically if you're
new to this, uh, game you basically run a
cam studio with a women, our goal to-
day is to become the greatest cam pimp
studio of all time and where our needs
our neesh
is going to be thick asses. What if we
could only go with thick asses and latinas
alright so we're going to have to take
how do I play? I forgot, shit, you drag them right?
alright there you go now i remember
Im making a lot of money on this bi*ch
this is great probably shoud've done that
*pewds orgams seizer*
cAkE FARTING
think about this thick asses, cake farting
we're gonna make millions
we are gonna make millions here today bros
alright great now we can hire another girl
please
please donna
a latina with thick ass please
a thick ass
all I ask
is for a thick ass
a thick ass please
can I get a thick ass
all I ask
is for a thick ass
ALL I ASK
got milf tattoos
damnit NADIA
get the FUCK OUT
with Tiffany, teen fit
GET THE FUCK OUT OF MY OFFICE TIFFANY
okay we got asian, god damn it
chubby
that's close enough
Beli your hiring
now start eating that chocolate
we need one more hire
please
thick ass
give me dat ass
gIVE ME THAT ASS
GIMME THAT ASS
otherwise we are gonna have to broaden out horizons
okay we got Audrey
tenn, flat chest
*disappointed pewds*
just go
Audrey just go
okay we got Le-Lailani
asian, flat ches-
*more disappointment*
it's the-
what kind of business do you think this is Leilani?
GOOOO
Sarah
chubby, th-OH
*clap*
(GOTA THICK ASSS)
oh shit I forgot you got to pay them
fuck
great now I'm fuckin' broke
great, I hope you're happy
You gotta pay people now? What the fuck is this?
Okay, we can get a new item
alright, what do we got. we got cocaine
uh, we got
what, uh
YES
BUTT PLUG
Now we can hire someone else
whadda we got?
ZOEY
*sighs* oh my god zoey
you look like s-  you come from the fifth element
we got Audrey.
AUDREY
for the second goddamn time!
GO
just GO
Tiffany-
god damn it.
listen-
listen up, tiffany
you're hired
but for one reason-
to wear this butt plug, up your asshole
that's right.
and then-
buy me some fuckin' liquor
that's right.
people don't understand how hard it is to do what I do
you don't understand, I have to be tough with my girls
because otherwise,
it's gonna be too hard for me-
when I have to fire them.
alright, we're gonna have to promo
chubby
we're going with chubby, thick asses.
fuck, I gotta pay these hoes.
this is not good
this is NOT good.
shut up
we're fine, we're fine everybody, no one  panic.
we're fine!
alright, we got chubby and thick ass
that's our main goal.
JESSIE!
chubby MILF.
c'mere mama
c'mere mama, welcome to the family, mama.
wait, kyanna costs two dollars an hour?
$2 an hour?
what do you think I'm  some kind of millionaire?
2 dollars a fuckin' hour?
are you kidding me?
kyanna!
$2 an hour?
what do you think? money just grows on thre- trees?
GET THAT THICK ASS OUTTA THERE
tiffany
$1 off an hour
*laughs like a donkey*
she gets paid one dollar an hour to wear a butt plug and buy cigarettes.
yes
tiffany, you're my main bitch now.
you're my main bitch I take it all back.
someone is ruining my business to the-
THIRTY TWO!
THIRTY TWO DOLLARS AN HOUR?
WHAT THE FUCK IS WRONG WITH YOU?
god damn it, I've never been this pissed in my life.
alright, we got candace
huge tits
*claps*
fit
yes
but
64 DOLLARS AN HOUR?
Candace, go fuck youself
nikki, you look like tumblr shat you out
nikki, i, d-, uh, I despise you
1 dollar?
NIKKI YOU'RE HIRED
you're hired Nikki!
Welcome to the family Nikki!
*laughs*
I owe them so much fuckin' money. Jesus christ.
serious music plays
JESSIE IS NOW 64 DOLLARS AN HOUR?
JESSIE
Jessie!
I need you to quit
how do I FIRE PEOPLE?!
WHAT IS THIS HUMAN RESOURCES STOPPING ME?!
WHAT IS STOPPING ME FROM FIRING THESE BITCHES
I CANT EVEN- I CANT EVEN PAY YOU GUYS
fuck this is bad
this is really fucking bad
OHMYGOD NO!
this is real bad, this is real bad, this is-
we are not fucking finished
until I fucking tell you
if this continues I am gonna have to send Tiffany out there
in front of the camrea
an if that ever happens
thats when I know
I've lost it all
(NOT TIFFANY)
(NOOOOOOO)
(he lost it all)
:(
I need Tiffany out there alright
its not gonna work out otherwise
A  HUNDRED AND TWENTY SEVEN FUCKING DOLLARS (its eight pewds)
A FUCKING HOUR
WHAT THE HELL
*all of life's regrets appear before his eyes*
JESSIE
SHI- YOUR RUINING MY BUSSINESS
I NEED YOU TO STOP
I- Jessie I need you out
I need you the fuck- I need you out
I- Jessie it hurts
it hurts
your OUT
fuck
I still aint got no money
aruh
Tiffany
shut the fuck up Tiffany
Tiffany go to the sleazy hotel
do not contract any STDs
whatever the fuck you do
( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
thank god
we need another slot for another bitch
i mean lady
a lady
we need another lady
fuck I own so much money
fuck
come on on come on
jacksepticeye ( ͡° ͜ʖ ͡°)
come on jacksepticeye
yesyesyesyes
okay now
now we gonna invest
yes we are making progress here
we're making a bold move
listen up Jessie
♪Jessie's girl♪
here's some cocaine
alright some might think its unethical to give your employees cocaine
I say have you heard of productivity
now go
shake that ass
oh my god I owe so much money
Jessie if you run me out of business
I will never forgive you
FUCK Jessie's out of cocaine
will someone give Jessie some god damn cocaine
okay alright
alright here is whats gonna happen
you get two condoms
thats right you better WOOO
(what is this the sims)
go to this sleazy hotel
and work your magic
do NOT get STDs
SARAH CAUGHT AIDS
♪Hello darkness my old friend♪
GOD DAMN IT
if she has AIDS can she still be a Cam girl?
OHHHHHHH
AIDS girl make me that MONEY
HEHE
you know its kinda inspiring how despite having AIDS and all
she's still doing her job
she's still living
her day to day life
this game truly is inspiring
Sarah ran out of steroids
yeah well you should have thought about that before you got AIDS
how do I cure AIDS
I dont understand
(neither do the doctors)
surely there must be a way
unless we find a cure for AIDS
we are gonna go down real fucking fast
FINAL DAY!! :)
come on come on work harder
show me some titties
its 9pm
at 11
at 11 pm I'm sending everyone to the whore house
to get that last bit of cash
Jesus Christ
ITS 11pm!
NOOO
I didn't get to send them to the whore house! :(
did I beat my record?
I BEAT MY RECORD!
♪I WISH THAT I HAD JESSIE'S GIRL♪
♪I WISH THAT I HAD JESSIE'S♪
we only got AIDS and that was it
*scary*
NOO
FUCK
GOD DAMN IT
FUCK YOU